sue ukraine let's listen in i want to
begin by thanking president zielinski
for his passionate message this morning
i listened to it in the private
residence and uh
he was convincing and
significant speech
he speaks for people who have shown
remarkable courage and strength
in the face of brutal aggression
courage and strength that's inspired not
only ukrainians but the entire world
putin is inflicting appalling appalling
devastation and horror
on ukraine
bombing apartment buildings maternity
wards hospitals
i mean it's god-awful i was speaking
about this with
our our
our commander behind here
general milley i mean
it just is amazing
yesterday we saw reports that russian
forces were holding hundreds of doctors
and patients
hostage and the largest hospital in
mario pool
these are atrocities
they're an outrage to the world
and the world is united in our support
for ukraine and our determination to
make putin pay a very heavy price
america is leading this effort together
with our allies and partners providing
enormous levels of security and
humanitarian assistance that we're
adding to today and we're going to
continue to do more in the days and
weeks ahead
we're crippling putin's economy with
punishing sanctions that's going to only
grow more painful over time with the
entire
nato and eu behind us and many other
countries
what's at stake here
are the principles that the united
states and the united nations and across
the world stand for
it's about freedom
it's about the right of people to
determine their own future
it's about making sure ukraine never
will never be a victory for putin no
matter what advances he makes on the
battlefield
the american people are answering
president zlinski's call
for more help more weapons for ukraine
to defend himself more tools to fight
russian aggression
and that's what we're doing
in fact we started our assistance in
ukraine before this war began as they
started to do exercises along the
ukrainian border the russians started in
march of last year
we took the threat of putin invading
very seriously we acted on it we sent
ukraine more security assistance last
year 650 million dollars in weapons
including anti-air and anti-armor
equipment before the invasion
more than we had ever provided before
so when the invasion began they already
had in their hands the kinds of weapons
that needed to counter russian advances
and once the war started we immediately
rushed 350 million in additional aid to
further address their needs
hundreds of anti-air systems thousands
of anti-tank weapons
transport helicopters
arm patrol boats
and other high mobility vehicles radar
systems that help track incoming
artillery and unmanned drones
secure communications equipment and
tactical gear
satellite imagery and and
analysis capacity
and it's clearly helped ukraine inflict
dramatic losses on russian forces
on saturday
my administration authorized another 200
million dollars to keep a steady flow of
weapons and ammunition moving to ukraine
now i'm once again using my presidential
authority to actively
activate an additional security
assistance to continue to help ukraine
fend off russia's assault
an additional 800 million dollars in
assistance
that brings the total of new u.s
security systems to ukraine to 1 billion
just this week
these are the large these are direct
transfers of equipment from our
department of defense to the ukrainian
military to help them as they fight
against this invasion
and i thank the congress for
appropriating these funds
this new package on its own is going to
provide unprecedented assistance to
ukraine
it includes 800 anti-aircraft systems
to make sure the ukrainian military can
continue to can continue to stop the
planes and helicopters that have been
attacking their people and to defend our
ukrainian airspace
and at the request of president
zielinski we have identified
and are helping ukraine acquire
additional longer-range anti-aircraft
systems and the munitions for those
systems
our new assistance package also includes
9 000 anti-armor systems
these are portable high
high accurate high accurately high
accuracy shoulder mounted missiles that
the ukrainian forces have been using
with great effect to destroy invading
tanks and armored vehicles
it will include 7 000 small arms machine
guns shotguns grenade launchers to equip
the ukrainians including the brave women
and men who are defending their cities
as civilians and they're on the
countryside as well
and we're and we and as well as the
ammunition artillery and mortar rounds
to go with small arms 20 million rounds
in total 20 million rounds
this will include drones which
which uh demonstrates our commitment to
sending our most cutting-edge systems to
ukraine for its defense
and we're not doing this alone our
allies and partners have stepped up to
provide significant shipments of
security assistance and will continue to
help facilitate these deliveries as well
the united states and our allies and
partners are fully committed to surging
weapons of assistance to the ukrainians
and more will be coming
as we source additional stocks of
equipment that are all that we're ready
to transfer
now
now i want to be honest with you
this could be a long and difficult
battle
but the american people will be
steadfast in our support of the people
of ukraine in the face of putin's
immoral unethical attacks on civilian
populations
we are united in our abhorrence of
putin's depraved onslaught and we're
going to continue to have their backs as
they fight for their freedom their
democracy their very survival
we're going to give ukraine the arms to
fight and defend themselves through all
the difficult days ahead
we're going to continue to mobilize
humanitarian relief to support people
within ukraine and those have been
forced to flee ukraine in just the past
few weeks we provided 300 million
humanitarian assistance to the people in
ukraine and in neighboring countries
tens of thousands of tons of food water
medicine and other basic supplies to
support the people in need
our experts on the ground in poland and
moldova
and other neighboring countries
are there to make real-time assessments
of the rapidly evolving crisis to get
urgently needed humanitarian supplies of
the people in need when they need it
and we will support ukraine's economy
with direct financial assistance as well
and together with our allies and
partners
we will keep up the pressure on putin's
crumbling economy isolating him on the
global stage
that's our goal
make putin pay the price weaken his
position while strengthening the hand of
the ukrainians on the battlefield at the
negotiating table
together with our allies and partners
we're going to stay the course
and we'll do everything we can to push
for and end this tragic unnecessary war
this is a struggle to pitch the
appetites of an autocrat
against humankind's desire to be free
and let there be no doubt no uncertainty
no question
america stands with the forces of
freedom
we always have we always will
i thank you all and god bless you and
i'm going to walk over and sign this
legislative sign this bill to allow the
drawdown out of those materials
and may god protect their
young ukrainians who are out there
defending their country
u.s president joe biden delivering
remarks on u.s assistance to ukraine as
he prepares to sign that and this is
coming after ukraine's leader earlier
addressed the u.s congress asking for
more support to fight off russia joe
biden described the ukrainian leader
vladimir zelensky as convincing
saying that he'd made a significant
speech the u.s president saying
america would continue to have ukraine's
back in the fight against russia let's
bring in our white house correspondent
kimberly harkett kimberly president
biden announcing new u.s security
assistance to ukraine
yes but stopping short of what vladimir
zelinsky asked for specifically just
hours ago in front of the u.s congress
in a very emotional plea in fact a
direct challenge to the u.s president it
has been at least initially outright
rejected by the u.s president and given
the delay of the speech by the u.s
president there was some speculation
that this was a plea that was under
serious consideration but it appears for
now
that this has again been rejected the
call for a no-fly zone the call for
these uh fighter jets that are referred
to as migs that have been on the ground
in poland that potentially could be
transferred for use in ukraine not going
to be operational at least for now now
is there the possibility in the future
the u.s president certainly has not
ruled that out he said uh that there is
the possibility for this to be done in
the future but for now the u.s president
very clear and very specific in what is
going to be sent in other words
anti-aircraft systems anti-armor systems
small arms and drones again falling
short of what was asked for by the
ukrainian leader before the u.s congress
how was the speech uh president
zelinski's speech in congress uh which
as you said was very emotional how was
it received by u.s lawmakers
it was enormously well received by the
u.s congress both democrats and
republicans giving the ukrainian leader
a standing ovation in a divided congress
this is one area where they all agree
and so that is notable
there is growing support and growing
pressure on the biden administration
to potentially support or at least
consider a no-fly zone as well as
potentially these
mig-jets that are in poland
whether or not they could be used and
the reason that the white house is
pushing back is because not only fears
of potentially a catastrophic effect of
a nuclear war but more imminently that
there is the potential for u.s or nato
fighters to come in direct confrontation
with russian fighters and for the
opportunity for that to escalate and
that is the greatest fear of the u.s
president right now so in some ways the
call by vladimir zelinski was for him to
be a leader of the world and to bring
about peace some might argue that's
exactly what he's doing is resisting the
temptation to see this escalade in order
to bring about peace to preserve peace
but again in the short term this is not
what the ukrainian leader was hoping for
kimberly hellcat at the white house
thank you very much for that and we'll
have more on the